I might do a little different and unique
but at the end of the day like I have
the same heart Sara Heron is one of many
people to appear in The Bachelor
franchise you've seen her on The
Bachelor bachelor in paradise but she's
one of very few people using her reality
TV Fame for a cause greater than
yourself we are here at your she lifts
photo shoot event celebrating one year
how does that feel to be celebrating one
year of this amazing organization it's
really really unbelievable I think is
the best way to describe it so awesome
Peron founded she lifts in August 2016
the nonprofit empowers young women
through outdoor adventures and
mentorship sara is Lim different and
growing up she struggled with
self-confidence I originally signed up
for The Bachelor because I was so
insecure with my arm that I I couldn't
date I couldn't put myself out there and
I thought as crazy as it sounds maybe if
I sign up for The Bachelor and I go on
and my stories out there for America to
see I can't hide from it anymore and
when the show aired and I started
getting messages from girls across the
country who could relate that was when I
realized what an incredible opportunity
I had been given for she lifts latest
campaign harren gather fellow bachelor
nation alumni and she lifts ladies at a
photo shoot money raised will help send
young women on a ski retreat I was like
begging her to have me be a part of it
bring you know girls together who you
know have the same differences and they
can learn from each other there's just
something about bringing girls together
and empowering in young girls who are
already struggling with the bullying and
the social media that was just honored
to be
to be acquired so it's really cool
they're all so genuine it's been amazing
oh my gosh like I saw her on TV and like
I get to like actually share a lot of
experiences with her and just meeting
other girls that are like me it really
helps so you don't hear their stories of
you know if they've been bullied as well
to meet people like me and it's just it
helped a lot today is one of the best
days of my life I mean just connect with
everyone and showing a lot of labs and
and we did the bachelor girls and the
fact that they're supporting she lived
in which means a lot to me and Tara's
organization is helping other girls with
physical differences and as a person
with cerebral palsy that means a lot to
me Sarah is amazing
so it's so fun so down to earth she's
easy to talk with she's very intuitive
and very smart she picks up on a lot of
things that maybe aren't easy to discuss
but she's like then she understands and
she can relate which is so important
whether you struggle with like the light
let me know I'm like okay this is how I
struggle like this how we can make it
better
you
[Applause]